[Music]
[Applause]
that voice is the voice of what do you
know the highest-paid offensive lineman
and NFL history Trent Brown sitting
here--he swagged out we got we got the
jacket we got some flannel pattern we
got the red top with the polo the fresh
glasses
the watch is blinding blinding how you
feeling man
you liking this rod Simba Beach
shout-out to rod set out to rod yes Cena
beyblade
how has this been man these last few
weeks have had it been wild seriously
honestly feel fake fake like so when
people say life is like a movie now you
know what they're talking about and I
started saying that just being know I
started saying that a couple years ago
just I mean some of the things I was
privy to because I had a few extra
dollars now I know the real meaning like
this is my first official prisoner a lot
of interviews since the Super Bowl right
non-stop interviews free media night of
Super Bowl how many reporters really
came up to you to talk to you I don't
even know I was actually at the hospital
right with my girl we had our son that
sued ah yes he was in labor for two days
you had a son the week of the Super Bowl
and then in the offseason got the
biggest cut trend bro this has to feel
things what do you feel what do your
prayers sound like these days like how
thankful are you man I've always given
God his just do he gets all the credit
for me none of this would be possible
without oh yeah
so what what is what have you had a
chance to like sit down and let it I
haven't I've been non-stop on the go
doing days doing that trying to make
sure my family is good
yes sir I'm gonna try to make sure my
business stuff is good yes yeah uh how
many kids do you have now two two what
are their ages nine months and seven
weeks oh my god bro welcome thank you I
mean I don't have any kids I'm saying
welcome like I got kids I have no idea
he's praying for you but it's
life-changing yeah and then because it
gives you perspective but I would
imagine playing for the Patriots gives
you perspective and when in a Super Bowl
gives you what have you learned through
all this thus far sorry I'm just like
taken aback
I'm Adam for you I really learned much
I've remained constant in myself through
the whole process
nothing has changed me I've I was just
telling my family and then last week
even though I signed the contract I
don't feel any different
I mean of course there's more sense of
security there more commas
yeah I'm still common folk yeah
your necklace that I'm seeing was also
the shirt logo you were wearing during
your press conference what is this what
are we working with here
Phoebe 7-7 TV sitcom TV 7-7 is just my
initials in my numbers sure the greatest
underdog is really just explains itself
really just want to let people know out
there especially kids that you can do
anything you want to do all you got to
do is believe in yourself you don't need
anybody else to believe in the other
than yourself you have yourself and God
in the sky's the limit what's funny
about an NFL player is we always look at
the giraffe as like the birth right so
for you a lot of people will say you're
an underdog because seventh round draft
pick and then all of the question marks
and the Niners and then the trade all
that stuff but I'm curious when did you
being an underdog start like when did
when does the I don't think you going
7th was the lowest part
well I've honestly been an underdog my
whole life even in Little League
I've always been put on the back burner
I was never that chosen one so to speak
but I always knew that I had greatness
in me it only a matter of time before
God was willing to willing and ready to
reveal it to the world because I know
one guy that saw really early von Miller
my guy Vaughn yeah and I'm um I went
back and I'm looking at all these
stories and I'm realizing that Vaughn
said that you were the best right tackle
me and I felt had you even play to have
you even played him yet
I had him it was just from it was just
from a new squad practice in case you
guys had an inner squad practice and the
reporters go who's the best right tight
who was the best talk to you face to the
NFL and he goes Trent Brown and you
hadn't even that was just my second camp
in the league my second year hadn't even
started yet I had I had four starts
under my belt at that point right
and they went well but it wasn't like
nobody was sitting around going he's the
best right dad had to catch you off
guard he did I had no clue somebody
people were seeing to me the clips from
the interview and I'm like dang he said
that I just saw him two days ago I mean
it was crazy
changed everything what did it change
what could one quote change I mean I
think it's just brought it with more
awareness to me I mean and the writers
or whoever they may say like you said
all the question marks whatever do block
yeah
but the respect of my peers is what
matters most because those are the guys
that actually played downs and step in
between those lines I'd have to get
around you and they know they know when
they play Trent Brown that they got it
they gonna have a day what's funny is
there were all these hints for us then
there's this Joe Staley quote where he
goes I don't throw this around lightly
he can be as good as anyone the NFL
that's ever been you see him and you
think Jonathan Ogden
he's Jonathan Ogden esque Jonathan Ogden
is like on the Mount Rushmore of tackles
of all time he was the original dancing
bear he helped Thicke turn that
Cleveland Browns into the Baltimore
Ravens he was the offensive piece that
was consistent with Ray Lewis on the
defensive side
I mean but none of these quotes were
taken seriously I felt like I felt like
they were all said but then no one ran
with him
I mean of course when you got people
that can control the narrative you know
they can dim your light and they can
make that go away yeah we're talking
about I'm gonna Charlemagne who are you
talking about whoever we talking about
San Francisco yeah it was it's gotta be
a weird time man because one there's
this trade that happens where you're
like this secondary piece almost and
then you end up being holding it down on
the left side for the greatest
quarterback that's ever lived in some
people's minds and Tom Brady like that
had to feel like vindication like how
did you because I said this to Davante
Adams last week I said when I was
younger I definitely was fueled by hate
for a little bit like early parts of my
career I'd see other people celebrating
or I'd say all right I know how they
felt now but I would use that but then
after a while you got to burn clean you
can't rely on that or else it'll make
you feel that way how much did it fuel
you in the beginning it's there for you
let me really not not from a bad place
but just the motivation to keep going a
lot of people just like now I'm here a
lot of people probably saying oh he got
that this is he no they say in the last
you don't hate it turn brown I almost
think well definitely not but I almost
think it could be better for you that
people are saying that like look I'm
gonna put everything on the table and
keep it a hundred I said the only thing
that scares me is you're going from
Dante scar Nekia and I'm not insulting
your former coach from the outside
looking in do not comment on this tom
cable the only reason I'm saying is Tom
has had a few rough offensive lines in a
row and I would argue Dante's Carnegie
is the greatest offensive line coach of
all time but do I think that's going to
determine how this turns out this year
absolutely not like this comes down to
you and it comes down to Colton and it
comes down to the coaching staff and all
that but I I can see it in your eyes
right now you're sitting there going you
think I'm a [ __ ] fail bro like I can
see it you know yeah
this is this is just the beginning
you I want to talk we'll talk Patriots
in the Super Bowl run but I'm curious
about the contract
where were you when you got the call
truth in Miami and Drew Rosenhaus so
were you expecting a call like how what
was the day tell me what the day was
like I mean I knew my friend she started
Monday was this tampering period started
it was just man the offer I mean it was
why are you sitting what were you in a
hotel I mean I was at the we had a
Airbnb I won I was down there with my
family I wanted to be down there close
to drill sure so I mean if anything
happened which was expected I would be
close and he wouldn't have to try to
find me right it's a flight or whatever
but was he telling you beforehand it
could get busy early yeah oh so you
there right it is a bus he said it was
gonna happen fast I mean half the league
showed interest really yeah
did you grow up rooting for a team I
didn't know I was looking at where you
went to school and I was like I don't
know who he was rooting for I just grew
up a play I've always been more of a
player fan I would actually grew up a
Randy Moss fan Randy Moss is the number
one you put the hand up when he even
he's leaving monster when everyday
mmm-hmm so you're sitting there and
you're with your family and how many
minutes go by from the start of the
tampering period free agency and all
that before you get a call I don't know
how I'm how many minutes I've heard nine
minutes and drew sent me text money bags
the emoji all these set was money bag
emojis the like six of them and then did
you tell people money bag emoji or are
you just sitting there like here we go
no I just knew it had to be something
because drew don't send emojis you don't
so he was like I can't wait to update
you I mean I was like where are you
who's like I'm at home and I will be
there would you I would have been there
ago what does he mean by six money bags
that sixty million dollar like well
that's kind of what happened so so then
what happens after that
I showed it to his house and he actually
had three offers on the table but the
one I chose was a no-brainer really
yeah what were the other tables I think
that's the interesting thing about Bill
is he goes go out and find your worth
and then if you want to come back you
can come back but the Raiders what was
it about the offer other than the number
I guess that really caught your
attention or the number 2 oh because
what we'd like to see that number Trent
I'm gonna shut up I'm a seventh rounder
I've been playing for pennies you know
and I got to Cheers I got a family that
I want to take care of I want to retire
my parents and this is the best
opportunity to do that but to see it
well I was like to see it man
I mean I didn't see you know I saw it on
paper on paper and just soak it all in
yeah man and then were you nervous
signing it I was really excited though I
really don't get nervous I only get
nervous on game days but wait so you you
sign it you everyone shaking your hands
they're saying congratulations
and then who was the first one that told
you this is gonna make you the
highest-paid offensive lineman of all
time
drew throw me how did he say it did he
say with a curse
[ __ ] this is gonna make you the
highest-paid offensive lineman of all
time man
this is great and are you just like are
you just like thank you like I'm I mean
I'm speechless
I mean cuz I remember drew Kent the
first time I saw drew was through the
agent panel at University of Florida
meeting with agents going through the
process blah-dee-blah and drew told me
that the plan all along was he was like
all right we're probably not gonna get
drafted high or whatever but uh we're
gonna get you an extension in three
years so I'm thinking I'm gonna get in
this tension wherever I go right
San Fran I was thinking I was gonna get
an extension right to get traded I was
completely blindsided by that and then
just to have to play out my whole
contract not knowing we in a Super Bowl
and free agency for that time perfect
time yeah guys timing is impeccable do
you hug the crap out of Georgie left him
off the ground no idea
now you kept it civil yeah all right but
what an awesome time you meet Jon Gruden
I'm sure you walk in did he say anything
that you remember anything funny I was
gonna walk up to you just be like look
at you full of energy is gonna be great
platform yeah
what was the first time walking in
meeting Belichick like cuz he's so
low-key I uh when I got traded first
first night of the draft I was actually
here in New York at dinner when I found
out it was gonna happen and then you
know I got a call and said oh we got to
make another pick here but we're gonna
get you on the phone with him is Nancy
here comes to get you a flight here for
a physical and gonna try to get this
thing worked out see you tomorrow so I'm
sitting there in the office and he he
comes in off in the office and he's like
Trent we brought you here to play tackle
we don't know which one is gonna be
we're not giving you anything you're
gonna have to work for it but we brought
you in to play in here to play tackle
and that was it you said let's go let's
go walk it in that locker room the first
time different way different really I
mean cuz you go from San Fran lockers
locker room is huge you know I mean
brand new all that stuff for new TVs
bright lights and then you go into New
England's lock room and you just feel
just the whole like facility you just
feel like history and tradition I mean
yeah and so
I was a slightly skidded did you did you
feel yourself change it all over this
year like what what did that experience
do do do you think I think I started I
fell in love with the game again that's
awesome
it wasn't uh it didn't feel like work
and I mean we had fun which is funny
because from our perspective the fan
perspective from the outside New England
seems like the one that worked the most
you know it's the hardest they're the
only ones where you're running sprints
after practice this is true but I mean
we we work hard but we work smarty
Smarties with meanness and I think they
just understand the process how things
be and I respected it appreciated it and
how can you as one piece of the 53 as
one piece of all the coaching staff and
all the staff they have their bring that
to Oakland huh you don't I mean like I'm
sure everyone's trying but how is it
just you taking care of yourself and
then the rest handles the rest when I
feel like it's being a team is like a
car everything everybody has to pull
their own weight in order for the car to
run I can I can control what I can
control and just move hard move yeah you
know I'm not gonna change anything now
because I'm the highest-paid office
lemon he's know yes I'm sure I'm still
gonna be Trent Brown I'm still a regular
person yeah you know I mean I'm still
gonna be the same humble down-to-earth
guy Trent Brown is in the locker room
Tom Brady walks up to him for the first
time since hi I'm Tom what was that like
I was kind of well I actually walked up
to him it was time for a team meeting
and I was it was one of the it was in
mini camp and um he had gotten there he
was with mr. Kraft and I walked up to
him I was just like cuz I first I was
kind of hesitant I was like do I do it
now yeah like this is what your dad
taught you to do like this is the man
thing to do so I got up and introduced
myself and he was like nice to meet you
and uh rest is history what is he
yelling about all the time he doesn't
you know not to the offensive linemen
never what I he he if any if anything is
motivation or motivation is good yeah
like stuff like that it's never
he's never test eyes and they're getting
in anybody's eyes like you saw yeah when
you play the Patriots it feels like
you're going up against this emotionless
machine right like when you were on the
Niners and you play the Patriots or
something like that you'd be like these
guys are just focused when you are part
of the Machine and you're going into
people's places and you're beaten
Chicago in Chicago or they cover you're
beating the Chiefs in Kansas City what
does it like to be a part of the Machine
great honestly I remember telling him
after the game he was like bro so what
he feel like I'm like probably the
stakes were at our all-time high and I
didn't feel any pressure
it was cold as hell out there that's all
I felt other than that you know I mean
he was he was I was yeah like I had no
doubt in my mind of course when they was
that last turn over d4 would've been
outside it'll be a different story but I
mean no doubt in my mind I'm like that's
too much time we got to go back here is
he the goat the goat of our goats the
goat of all goats
the koteas goat the go-to you scope over
Jordan Brady over Jordan I mean I played
yes was d4 lined up over you on that
play
mm-hmm did you know he was offsides out
of my peripheral it'll close but I mean
it is what it is yeah gotta play ball at
the end of the day and then unbelievable
I mean that when the when the ref made
that call I mean you guys must like your
heart was probably in your chest
because I'm like because the pig was in
a peak and then I'm like I'm walking to
the side I'm like damn it's over we're
going home right I said it's talks going
I'm like what's going on what's going on
while we still out here it's a flag
outside first though in terms of your
guys playoff run melvin Ingram and Joey
Bosa zero sex
Justin Houston d4 Chris Jones zero sex
Aaron Donald and AMA consumed on teh
Fowler zero sex how did that happen
how'd y'all pitch a shutout our our line
was a tiny group and coast car is a
great coach and we start gelling and
rolling at the perfect time in the year
when did it click oh I think we really
started kind of clicking around the
Minnesota game I don't know what week
that was but the Minnesota ain't Kimmy
you guys Kirk Cousins couldn't do
anything and then your offense was just
moving yeah and and then I would just
kept getting closer and closer we I mean
we were always close I mean this is a
close-knit group before I get tightening
groups sure I got there but they
welcomed me in with open doors
everybody treats each other with respect
this family yeah through and through and
I think that played a big role in the
success we had I can tell you a story
from the Super Bowl where we used to be
laughed about after the game but so
Coast Guard had broke it down I have one
of our practices during the week I
believe that Thursday I don't greet and
he broke it down by the start of
practice and we so Marcus has said break
it down on grit and everybody kind of
looked around like but get out of here
you know me but then David said it was
like what do you say boys
great for a world championship break
down I agree for where a championship
and everybody just you know they put
their hands and it was just it was just
the five of us nobody else yes the five
of us and that was the best driver of
the season we
I bet we can all probably say that I
mean we broke a couple long runs and
grant came up with the kids
and you just felt like in that huddle
saying grit and letting the hands go up
I mean I feel like we were varsity blues
[Laughter]
come on boy just and you're moving and
the full-back is in there and that's
awesome to lift the trophy to kiss it
twice twice first was it was it to look
at your teammates to see the confetti
like the most emotional I mean the road
it is taken for me to get here someone
would say the road let's travel and to
be seen in these tears I mean it's all
this is the honor you being here with me
get the [ __ ] in there
I appreciate it I'm looking at your
school's high school Westover
comprehensive high school Georgia
Military College where are these places
like I feel like this is instilled so
much into you but what are those schools
even like because I've never heard
schools called that before I know a
military school which made me understand
maybe why you fit in with the Belichick
the whole thing but Westover like what
were these places like it was a high
school okay
it's funny because me we playing the
same team in high school I mean we were
three and seven and we're City champs
three at seven to City Wow could call
ourselves champs of some sort but and
they judge Military College I would
never regret that decision there's a bit
decision I made in my life
how come I hope I hope that plays near
and dear to my heart forever just the
relationships I formed I got numerous
amount of friends lifelong relationships
I got a brother that plays right over
the road here Neville Hewitt yeah Jess
that's my brother
to the grave so is this like a JUCO type
of situation your primary school mm-hmm
what was that life like it was easy
yeah how come because for me I'm crazy I
mean I don't have I'm not grabs never
had it I've never had an issue with
following rules yeah yeah I have my oath
on my parents or retired military my
dad's still the police I was in my mom's
a schoolteacher so Wow authority has
never been an issue respecting
authorities never been a issue for me
respect period has never been an issue
for me yeah so I don't understand how
someone that is six 8380 who has shown
what you've showed on the national stage
time and time again with a military
background with a mom that's a teacher
and the dead that's retired military an
ax cop and your mom was retired military
too so I didn't want to forget that can
somehow just get traded for nothing [ __ ]
bro what were they seeing what were they
seeing uh I don't know what they were
seeing you're not a distraction you're
not an annoyance you're not someone a
lot like what the [ __ ] happened just I
mean I guess people people feel like I
just say I just put it like this
sometimes business becomes personal
sometimes I don't know why but probably
because I chose to not play the rest of
the seasons because so to have soldier
surgery because done to end guys andrews
recommended really use like you gotta
have surgery it was like you risking
your career here damned if you don't
maybe in the season that you guys
couldn't make the playoffs anyway right
playing for pride but it is what it is
man well thank God you didn't play and
you got the surgery and you went to
England and now you're on the Raiders
and now you got guys like a Antonio
Brown on your team did you sign before
after that trade happened no he was
already found so he had already gotten
traded did that make it even more it's
not the same day but he was already
traded it was the same day I knew it was
the same thing but how much works I
think ain't happen like that Saturday or
Sunday and
happened the Monday how exciting is that
it's cool because I mean we have we
really kind of found a relationship over
here over the past year I remember last
year we were working out I was finishing
up a workout and he was probably
starting his eighth workout of the day I
mean I know but he does I don't know how
many times but he does work a lot and so
uh
he was just like dang bro you is some
about you got that glow and I'm sure he
would know cuz we got similar stories
yeah six around traffic Central Michigan
and overlooked yeah absolutely and yeah
we find the kind of AB on social media
stains phone numbers yeah the bay is
getting the brown boys is that what you
guys are gonna call each other the brown
boys the best part too is you're so
opposite you're huge Antonio Brown is
like a smaller guy man there's some
opportunities there the brown boys
robbed and beat rather what's it like
for you in airports [ __ ] awful huh I
mean going to the airport is not bad but
being on the plane yeah I can't use the
bathroom I can't do anything I just sit
there in my seat hoping that we likely
don't have to fly coach anymore have you
ever had to do that yeah probably a lot
when I was taking visits I took a visit
to Arizona they couldn't give me first
class cuz that's considered extra
benefits when that mean wow you got a
guy seeks a singing coach they will try
their hardest to give me a zero but do
you even fit like your needs even get it
like under the seat or do you have to go
like diagonal it's hard need to buy like
two seats it's hard I say that I met
more the airport cuz I feel like
everyone would be like hi I don't know
who you are but like I'm not okay no
that doesn't happen to you now I don't
even give off like you can't even smell
famous on that's how regular I am and
that's how regular you just don't want
to be you rub like like bread on yeah
I'm just normal I'm just noise isn't
this isn't a sense excitement about the
Raiders excited to get going when when
the next step of the process when is it
season mode when's that switch click on
um I say the season they were ended uh I
took a couple days off after Super Bowl
and I was back to working out you
telling me you didn't celebrate that
contract at all I haven't celebrated you
have a big dinner when I mean yeah a
nice dinner so I guess so celebrating
equals me going and packing up and
getting on a u-haul and driving it takes
us in a minute a night with my family to
move to take this yeah we got to work on
your celebrated skills what have you
made a purchase yet really nothing all
right well the first thing we're gonna
do is I usually give left Co PR which is
like advice but I think that story is
good enough advice and I think that
letting people know that you haven't
done that yet is amazing bro I mean I
don't I don't need anything I have
everything I need
also I know how Antonio Brown talks so
the fact that he looked he was like yeah
you've got a glow like he Antonio Brown
is like he's like an energy field the
first time I met him I was like he's on
something
and you just realized that's just his
aha that's just his energy he's just a
different cat you know I think he played
the whole NFL with that mustache thing I
think that whole thing was just to get
him out of Pittsburgh and it was smart
it was really smart it's good strategy
I'm excited for you I wish you the best
do you have any expectations like now
that you've you've conquered that
mountain about winning a Super Bowl and
you've you secured the bag and you're
feeling good how will you keep
motivating yourself I'm motivated by the
same things that motivated me before and
if anything I got to be little kids that
as motivation enough and my parents my
parents don't want to quit I want them
to so bad but you're trying to retire
your parents yeah but they won't quit so
that's motivation to keep going as well
awesome bro any message for Raider
Nation out there no I mean I'm excited
to be coming to the black hole would be
a point of Raider Nation baby that's
awesome congratulations the main man the
66 million dollar man
and Trent Brown Von Miller called him
the best tackle on the NFL Joe Staley
says he's kind of like John Ogden
now he's got a super ball now he's paid
and now he's the starting left tackle or
right tackle I don't know has that been
announced yet does it even matter
whatever side Derrick card needs to be
blocked he's blocking Trent Brown you're
the [ __ ] man dude thank you
appreciate it